that game Magnus has thrown up he is
playing good okay that's good news yeah
yeah that is good news we will jump into
that game when this one finishes with a
win maybe for Prague
looking that way this is a very
important night check he's just given
the black king now running out of
squares he doesn't really want to walk
into the eye line of the White Queen
maybe now white can exchange Queens by
by moving into the center yeah
um because the black kings wandered a
long way unless the song okay he's gone
this way as well so similar idea big
Checkmate threat Queen coming back to G2
potentially to deliver Checkmate also
the White Queen can come back to the
first rank check from the side oh did he
make a move
just about survived that uh scramble but
surely there's a Checkmate now and there
we go crack finds a really nice pattern
Checkmate next move and uh he takes the
win incredible 92 moves and a big battle
between two amazing teenagers it ends up
with a win for a young pragnananda